Larry what brings you to story expo 2014
I'm recognizing and and also pitching a
film in the TV series that I have a
feature film and the TV series of
basically I'm pitching character and the
character is in the movie in the
character is also the star of the series
Emma dimas so that I'm here to also see
what they're what they're looking for
and if anybody's looking for something
that's a little offbeat which they're
not I mean generally yeah so I'm trying
to find out what's going on on the other
side of the camera you know I'm kind of
explored acting I want to explore
writing and and filmmaking want to make
my own films eventually which I've been
doing actually and how long have you
been working on this specific idea 10
years 10 years okay well i mean i've
been working on the character for 10
years I've been filming him for 10 years
in writing for 10 years in different
places sometimes I had a show that I
started out with it with a show actually
my sister strangely enough sent me a
sketch I made in 1976 of a character
named Emmett who was an old guy you know
and this character Emmett that I'm here
to pitch is an old guy so I guess I've
been thinking about him since 1976
that's really weird and because I've
been working as an actor he's looking
for work or actually working or trying
to remember eyes lines I don't have much
time to actually become a filmmaker I
have ADHD so I can only think of maybe
ten things at once and so I took a
sabbatical about a year ago and I just
said ok I'm just going to work on
filmmaking so I have these three film
three mature films that I did about
Emmett and they won prizes all over the
all over the world actually
and then in festivals and stuff and I
thought okay I think I'm ready to write
the feature and act as in it so that's
what I that's why I'm here but why now
if you've had Emmett in your mind since
thanks well I think I'm old enough to do
him now and I've also figured out how to
write him in the long form you know film
shorts there there 10 minutes is not
long enough for me to develop what I
want to develop about him because I'm
it's a comedy and he's a comic character
like like Chaplin alike louis ck but you
have to really know a character I at
least in in my way of thinking and I
think I've made enough film shorts about
him and learned enough about the Ark of
character and stuff like that so that
that's why now I feel I'm ready for some
reason I don't know there's a voice
inside of me said okay do it now I mean
nobody told me to do it and yeah the
voices don't say anything back hey they
say go Florence oh those are good voices
and why do you feel that Oh may I see
the opposite know everybody says no
don't do anything ever about anything
ever I mean that's just how the universe
the human universe talks the other
universe is pretty cool it says go for
it if you see what I'm saying I do and
what what do you think the reasons
behind the human universe nobody wants
you to change because if you change and
they're not it's on them so let's
everybody just stay the same and we'll
all be in our comfort zone and let's not
talk about it okay that's good we won't
so I just you know when you won one day
some people wake up to that fact and I
woke up you know about I guess about two
three or four years ago I guy I said
that boy started to say hey man you know
I'm gonna just do this and they go no
you're such a good actor why don't you
just keep acting you know they say now I
want to be a filmmaker that's what I say
that's what the voices say but people
say yeah but don't you know your sex we
love you in like your agent you know
things like that why do you feel that
Emmet is to non-mainstream or whatever
the word is many times well so far I've
been pitching and that's the they said
he's kind of quirky that's what you get
that's that's what I've been getting
well he's kind of quirky and he is he's
totally quirky I mean you know just like
Louis CK is quirky or chaplain is quirky
or you know any other funny by Adam
Sandler's pretty quirky you know but
that shouldn't matter it never does I
mean you know the first guy is always
weird you know subscribe we're doing it
whatever well what are the notes that
you've gotten because you'd already
pitched today or no yeah the notes are
well we were kind of we're looking for
something more grounded we're looking
for something what's kind of quirky I
mean we make a lot of stuff for hallmark
so I like it I mean I really do but I
don't know if I you know I don't think
we would do something like this
basically so what I'm hearing is he's
too funny haha but that's that's the one
of the message idea Janet I come from
you know second city i come from the
committee I come from you know Charlie
Chaplin Louie CK Bob Dylan you know
Lenny Bruce you know Lenny Bruce was too
quirky I'm Dylan was too quirky they
were all too quirky anybody who's funny
is basically started out too quirky you
know yeah is there a way in your mind
you could tone Emmett down ah there you
go we're tones that would kill
no no I mean I've tried it other ways
it's not me I mean you know i would
rather this is so cliche but i would
rather do it my way at least i know that
when you turn me down it's something
that I wanted to do it's something that
I did sincerely and it's not for you I
could that's cool but if I do it your
way and you turn me down um eft because
what did I learn I didn't learn anything
by that you know so I'm also a student
you know so I got to get something out
of a no so if I do it my way and you
give me an O I've learned something if I
do it your way and I get an oh I've
learned nothing I think
you